c'était en plein confinement le 15 avril
dernier anne bonnassies reçoit une
demande de réservation d'une chambre
pour une semaine de la part d'un
espagnol en déplacement professionnel
depuis séville en avait plus personne et
plus d'activités et et lui voulaient
absolument il était indépendant il
voulait absolument continuer son
activité sur le golf national pour un
chantier avec le déconfinement les cinq
chambres d'hôtes et les gîtes avec ses
deux chambres se sont remplis mise en
place des gestes barrières mises à
disposition de masques et de gel
hydroalcoolique
toutes les mesures ont été prises pour
accueillir les clients j'ai eu des des
queues de chantier qui donc du personnel
qui devait finir des chantiers qui
avaient été démarré en janvier février
mars et qu'il souhaitait terminer leurs
chantiers qui nous ont sollicités pour
séjourner ici sans d'heure lui vient de
belgique durant toute la semaine ils
logent dans cette maison dans le cadre
de son activité professionnelle et
vanina ickx place
c'est un très bon endroit parce qu'après
le travail
tu peux prendre du temps pour te reposer
de ta journée le soleil et la beaujarde
1 c'est un peu comme des vacances après
la journée de travail
dans cet établissement les voyages
d'affaires représente 80% du chiffre
d'affaires
la gérante a une bonne assise
s'inquiètent d'un ralentissement de
l'activité à partir de la mi juin